hello everyone and welcome to the
laboratory testing an automation virtual
event my name is Rebecca pom piano and
I'm an assistant professor at the
University of Virginia and I'm going to
be sharing with you today some new
technology to combine the fluid control
of micro fluidics with the power of
intact live tissue samples I want to
remind you that you have to feel free to
submit questions at any time during the
presentation and I'll follow up with you
via email so please be interactive weird
like v start is by reminding everyone
that your tissues in your body are
highly spatially organized and what this
means is that the cells and molecules
that make up your tissues are arranged
so that they're touching each other in
specific ways and this of course enables
them to have functions that they
wouldn't have if they were all blended
up together and what you're seeing on
the screen are three images from three
different organs the lymph node the
brain and an ominous looking tumor and
what we notice is that their cells
clustered together there are fluids
passing through that we can't see but
they would be carrying any secreted
proteins or small molecules that are
released from one cell and then carried
to neighboring cells in order to have
paracrine signaling you can imagine that
if you took a brain sample and crushed
it up and homogenized it that it would
no longer have the same functions that
it has when it is in your head and yet
often that is how most most in vivo in
vitro experiments are done so what we
see is that people take cells that have
been blended and then they're either
plated onto a flat plastic plate or
suspended into a 3d hydrogel culture
usually in a homogeneous manner
occasionally with some spatial
organization that's forced into the
system and although this provides a lot
of experimental control it doesn't
enable you to ask questions of
how the tissue is organized or how cells
contacting each other in the way that
they did in vivo leads to function on
the other hand if you have an in vivo
experiments such as in a mouse or a
higher animal you are able to preserve
all of that spatial structure but you
lose the ability to drug the the tissue
of interest at will or easily to be able
to make measurements and so we really
need a hybrid method of looking at at
spatial structure in tissues there's a
number of people pursuing different ways
to do this including spatially patterned
cell cultures but here what I would like
to share with you is an alternative
approach but a few labs have been
developing and that is to combine the
power of ex vivo culture meaning samples
of tissue outside the body with micro
fluidics to control the environment so
here just to walk you through the
advantages and disadvantages of working
in a live sample of tissue I'm showing
you a table with the three different
modes of experimentation at the top and
then if we think about what what are the
features of working in vivo it's that
intact spatial organization that's
preserved if you're going to work in
slices but not if you're working in cell
cultures on the other hand if you're
working in slices you lose the
connectivity of the tissue to other
organs so for example if you're studying
the brain that brain is no longer
connected to the gut or the lungs once
you are working with a slice that could
be either an advantage or a disadvantage
depending on the questions that you
would like to ask on the other hand with
slices you're able to access sub
structures of tissue and organs that
would have been deep within the animal
and therefore not accessible to live--to
photon imaging or other analytical
methods and so you're able to bring out
some parts of tissue that you wouldn't
build a study in vivo on the flip side
there are features of working in slices
that are more akin to what you get in a
cell culture dish so it's just the
ability to repeatedly analyze
the same sample without having to do an
endpoint experiment for every time point
and the ability to deliver drugs at a
defined concentration and time within
the the dish or the chamber that you're
culturing the tissue in we can also
easily collect supernatant in order to
do downstream offline analysis of
secreted proteins or molecules and and
we can use simple wide field imaging
modalities instead of having to use
sophisticated two-photon microscopy so
by working in slices we sort of gain
most of the benefits of in vivo work and
cell culture work but it is a slightly
higher level of complexity than regular
cell culture work and so you do have to
get yourself set up for that so the way
that these samples are prepared is by
collecting the organ of interest from
either a human biopsy sample or from an
animal donor and then if it's a small
piece of tissue it's usually embedded in
a clear agarose gel or a physical
support and what you're seeing on the
screen and the center picture are three
samples of in this case murine lymph
node so lymph nodes from a mouse there
are a few millimeters in diameter and
they're embedded into agarose gel and
then those are sliced on an instrument
called a vibratory this is different
than a cryo tome or a micro tomb because
the tissues are still alive that that
means that they're soft they haven't
been fixed or frozen and so the
instrument is set to slice several
hundred micron thick slabs of tissue and
that ensures that only the top and
bottom faces are damaged by cutting
while the center is still a healthy
vibrant piece of so of course this is a
lab automation talk and so we're not
going to talk just about tissue we want
to put it into a piece of technology
that comes from the field of micro
fluidics and micro fluidics is perfectly
suited to study these tissue samples
because they're really at the larger end
of what a microfluidic chamber can
accommodate so when you're working with
tissues there
in a millimeter in diameter or perhaps a
few hundred microns in diameter and then
that leaves you with all of the lower
range of microfluidic length scales like
tens or hundreds of microns to control
the environment of the tissue so we're
able to for example deliver streams of
fluid locally to subunits of tissue or
to connect multiple tissues together and
those are things I'm going to share with
you later in the talk
the combination of ex-vivo slices and
micro fluidics has been around for
perhaps 15 years and it really began
with brain slices that makes sense
because brain was the first organ that
was really sliced frequently if I know
scientists and for decades now they have
been collecting and culturing tissue
slices either acute for just a few hours
to study the electrochemistry or even
for months in order to study development
of the brain and micro fluidics engineer
has quickly figured out that by using
fluidic control at the micro scale they
could more efficiently in control
nutrient and waste exchange and they
could control the gas environment around
the tissue often in a way that was more
controlled than in classic cell culture
dishes but we can go far beyond that by
using micro fluidics you can deliver to
just one part of the tissues shown there
in the orange circle while preserving
the ability to interface the device with
imaging and other and analytical
modalities and so this type of
technology has been applied by a handful
of groups around the world this is still
a small field and it would be exciting
if some of the of you listening today
decided to join this area and so used to
give you a sense of what is possible I'm
showing you four different types of
applications that have been pursued so
far we see some drug and toxicity
testing in the upper left that came out
of sabath their porches group in the
Netherlands back in 2010 where they
actually connected multiple types of
organs together I believe it was liver
and gut in order to look at metabolic
changes in response to drugs we've also
had mechanistic experiments where
microchips that were interfaced with
electrochemical arrays were used to map
out signaling in the brain there's
applications in personalized medicine
for example taking patient tumor samples
and putting them onto a chip in order to
test different combinations of
chemotherapy and that came from the
Gervaise lab in Montreal and then
interestingly a six-month-long culture
of testes tissue is shown in the lower
right and they were actually able to
guess from out of genesis and then breed
mice using the sperm that were produced
so this was highly viable tissue culture
for over six months and that came out of
Japan just a couple of years ago and so
you can see that there's a lot of
potential for using this type of
technology and combining the intact
tissue with its spatial organization
with the fluidics
what my lab works on is taking the
technology and using it to build new
tools for the study of the immune system
this is an area where there is there's a
lot of need for new tools in the field
of immunology
especially ones that look at spatial
structure as most of the advances in
immunology lately have come from either
single style analyses or flow cytometry
or in vivo imaging where there isn't
much control over what's happening in
the tissue at any given time and it's
mostly watching through window and so by
combining micro fluidics and chemistry
and immunology we hope to develop new
tools so that we can ask questions about
how your immune system is organized and
how that drives the spatial effects or
how that drives the the response in an
immune event so just very briefly orient
you on the tissue that you're going to
see featured in the rest of the top but
then we'll get back to
technology my lab really focuses on an
organ called the lymph node and you may
be familiar when that Wigan it's your
tonsils for example which gets swollen
when you have an infection and this is
an organ that is highly structured it's
similar to a brain where there are sub
structures that are responsible for one
function or another such as antibody
development or the development of killer
cells and they're scattered throughout
your body and strategic locations so
that you can respond appropriately to
infections in different parts of your
body when my lab has been developing for
the past few years is a method to
collect the lymph nodes from mice and
then slice those and we've tested
extensively the viability and the immune
function of those tissues ex vivo in
order to ensure that they can still
respond to inflammatory stimuli or other
immune stimuli and we have found that a
fly store like the one shown here still
preserves the spatial organization that
we would expect to see in vivo what
you're looking at is a piece of Mouse
lymph node that is alive and Culture and
we've labeled in green where the b-cells
are and in blue where the lymphatic
vessels are and we can see this
beautiful structure is preserved ex vivo
okay a with this technology what are
some of the things that are possible
what I'm going to share with you are two
short stories one using tissue slices in
fluidics to ask questions about local
events in the tissue and then the other
to ask about interactions between
multiple organs in the body so two
different levels of spatial organization
and we're going to start with local
stimulation okay so the question that
really drove me when I started working
on this several years ago was how two
local events trigger functions in the
body and again here we're talking about
immunity but this is just as real
in other organs such as the brain or the
gut or the lung that you may be
interested in and so we wanted to ask
what happens if you deliver a drug to
one part of an organism no there for
example how quickly does it spread
through the tissue and does that vary by
by area of the organ and then later we
might be able to ask questions about
triggering events and propagation
through tissue but how do you deliver to
just one part of a piece of tissue that
is only millimeters in diameter you can
imagine that pipetting here is quite
difficult especially when this is an
ambassador and we didn't want to insert
any micro needles into the tissue as
that that may damage it and cause there
to be a reaction that changes the
response so we took a cue from some
prior work out of David Eddington's lab
at the University of illinois-chicago
where he had laid a microfluidic channel
beneath the chamber holding a brain
slice and then used ports to deliver to
just one part of the brain tissue as
illustrated here and so what we did was
we adapted this down for the lymph node
and you can see the device design here
so there are three layers to this
microfluidic chip the bottom layer has
an array of channels the middle layer
has an array of ports where there's one
port per channel and then the upper
layer is simply a culture chamber where
you can lay your tissue and so the
concept is that you would choose a
feature of the tissue that you want to
deliver drug to for example maybe that
red area of the tissue is interesting
and then you would choose the channel
that has a port that terminates beneath
that region and deliver drug to it as
shown there in orange so we construction
this device out of three layers right
now it's just being out of
polydimethylsiloxane or PDMS using
standard photo lithography methods and
you see the image of the chip there on
the right with its large central
circular chamber where you can lay the
tissue and if we zoom in there
we can see the array of channels in the
lower layer and the array of ports on
top and you see that the ports are
scattered that's to increase the chance
that they fall under a region of
interest in the tissue so I want to show
you what it looks like when we do local
delivery we have here a fluorescent
image of a piece of tissue where it is
laid down of top the array of ports and
I've outlined that tissue and a white
dotted line and then we're delivering a
fluorescent probe through a channel
beneath and you can just barely see the
top of that channel at the top of the
image and then when we see the drugs
starting to come up through the port in
this semi radial fashion from the port
when we draw a line scan across the
image we find that these distributions
tend to be pretty Gaussian as you see in
panel B and then we can fit that
Gaussian curve in order to find the area
under the curve and the width of the
curve and that enables us to get a sense
of how much are we delivering and we see
that if we deliver longer we get a
linear increase in the amount of dye
that's in the tissue and we get linear
increases in the width of the pulse at
least for these short delivery times
eventually it will saturate the tissue
so we've pretty good control over
delivering drugs through regions of us
that do and you'll notice there in panel
B for the shortest or pulse times a few
seconds we can get resolution on the
order of a couple hundreds of microns
depending on the size of the molecule
and so for these protein size molecules
we tend to have two or three hundred
micro resolution and that's sufficient
to target sub structures of tissue such
as in the lymph node say a b-cell
follicle or the T cell zone or in the
brain you might be targeting part of a
cortex for example we did some fluid
modeling to understand whether these
pulses are going all the way through the
tissue and so what you see here is a
model of the cross section of the device
so there's the channel on the bottom
with fluid flowing through it you can
see the arrows and then on top is
supposed to be a slab of tissue which we
modeled as a porous matrix and what
we've done here is we've
load for five seconds a pulse of a drug
and the concentration of that drug is
shown here in the color scale and now
we're starting to flow buffer in behind
it and so what we see is there's this
ballooning of a spot of drug pushing up
through the tissue and then if we wait
one minute we see that you know with
buffer coming in behind it's gone up and
out the top of the tissue and is
beginning to be washed away so the
delivery is passing all the way through
the tissue and that's a feature of this
design where we're not just stimulating
the surface of the tissue
we're actually penetrating and getting
all the way through the depth of this
thick slab of tissue okay so that was
the first generation of this chip with
these stationary ports beneath the
tissue one drawback of that chip design
is that it means that if you lay down
your tissue and you wanted to deliver
somewhere that didn't happen to fall
over one of the ten ports you would need
to move the tissue manually in order to
get it to align with the port and that
isn't too hard for a highly trained
scientist but for someone who might be
new or if you want to just have
technicians doing this you might damage
your tissue by having to move it so we
had a vision of changing the chip
designs so that you could lay down the
tissue and then move a court to be
anywhere that you wanted it to be and as
you can imagine you can't move anything
in a solid block of silicon rubber so
this required a complete redesign of the
chip and I had a talented grad student
who took this on and so she created what
is referred to as a slip chip design
where we have a piece of tissue lying
atop an array of ports at this time we
have over 80 ports beneath the tissue
and then that array instead of being
directly connected to a channel is now
floating on a layer of oil below that is
an additional channel and and then a
single port and I've shown that shown
filter with green so what do you know
about oil and water they don't mix so
this is basically keep
completely separated the solution of
drug that might be in that channel down
below from the Culture Media that is
surrounding the tissue and then what you
can do is slip and slide the two layers
since they're lubricated by this layer
of oil in order to connect the port of
interest above with the channel below
and then you can turn on a pump and
deliver up and now you have delivery
akin to what we had in the other chip
and then we can just connect again and
turn off the pump in order to turn off
the flow and so my student Meg worked
out all the physics of this I got it's a
lot it's based on surface tension to
keep the delivery fluid from leaking out
into that oilfield layer and we found
that we were able to deliver selectively
to regions of interest repeatedly within
the same tissues and so we're continuing
to work on this design to move
completely away from ports and into more
of a membrane format so that we can
deliver truly anywhere on demand okay so
what might one do with a system like
this where you can locally deliver one
of the first applications that we
decided to target was to ask how do
molecules move through different parts
of the tissue because we know that in
tissue you aren't diffusing in a simple
way instead you're experiencing what's
called hindered diffusion and where
molecules have to move through the
tortuous spaces between cells and this
has consequences ranging from
development and repair of organs to the
paracrine signaling between cells and
importantly to drug delivery as you
think about a drug that has exited the
bloodstream and needs to travel several
hundred microns before it reaches a a
tumor or a region of interest in the
tissue it's doing that by diffusion and
effusion is currently measured in
tissues by either using frapp
fluorescence recovery after
photobleaching where you soak your
entire tissue in a die and then bleach
once and watch as the molecule diffuses
back in that works well for inert probes
but won't work well for a bioactive
molecule that might change the tissue
during the soaking time so instead we
wanted to use local delivery and that is
you
really done by some sort of needle and
started into the tissue and then imaging
or electrochemistry to watch it spread
but again we're worried with an immune
tissue and perhaps with other tissues as
well then inserting a needle that is
tens or hundreds of microns in diameter
into the tissue could cause damage that
changes the transport behavior that we
want to watch so this was a great
application for this gentle fluidic
delivery and so we took the device that
I just shared with you the simple one
where I am everything is stationary and
we simplified it further so we have just
a single channel and port beneath the
tissue and the goal here is to deliver
bioactive molecules into the tissue and
then watch their spread so typical
experiment looks like this you see on
the left and image of a piece of tissue
that we've labeled the B cells which
tend to be around the edges in green and
then we're delivering a red fluorescent
protein in this case it's tumor necrosis
factor-alpha that we labeled with
rhodamine dry and then we deliver for
five seconds and you see that in that
second image which is labeled zero
minutes so that becomes time zero is
that pulse of dye that's been delivered
to the center then we just stop the pump
and we watch over time as the molecule
diffuses away then we can quantify by
image and analysis the spread of that
molecule and back out the diffusion
coefficient and we validated this
against frappe in inert gels with
standard probes and found that we're
within two fold of reported measurements
so we're fairly confident in these
numbers and then we were able to make
the first measurements of the diffusion
of Sanna alpha and other bioactive
proteins moving through different parts
of the lymph node and and we were able
to see that indeed in the tissue versus
an inert Joe we do get slowing down of
the transport of these molecules
presumably due to binding which is what
you would expect whereas an inert
molecule like dextran shown on the Left
travels with the same diffusion
coefficient through all of these
materials so this is sort of a
demonstration that you can watch as
molecules move through the tissue by
using this sort of technology and we
envision that the
has applications and things like drug
delivery and studying paracrine
signalling and propagation through
tissue and so if any of you have
questions or ideas about that I'd be
happy to talk with you by email
afterwards okay so in the last few
minutes I'm just gonna share briefly one
other story which is using microfluidics
instead of looking at structures within
sis you to begin to think about bodily
level organization and multi organ
connection but as you know no one organ
in your body operates in isolation
they're connected via the blood and
lymphatic systems and the organ pair
that we were particularly interested in
was the lymph node of course and in this
piece connecting to a tumor as to
remember immunity is becoming a really
exciting area where there's potential to
take advantage of the immune system to
fight off patients tumors and so it's
known that tumors drain to the lymph
nodes near them through lymphatic
channels and then cells and molecules
from the lymph node can get back to the
tumor via your bloodstream and so we
wanted to make a model of this in
microfluidics in order to preserve the
intact tissue with their spatial
structure and that basic fluidic
connection and so my postdoc songs are
assumed designed a chip that with this
basic concept where you have a tumor and
lymph nodes slice each on the chip and
connected in a one-way loop of fluid
flow in this case for simplicity we
first put beneath each tissue a trackage
membrane that restricted cell movement
by having small pores and that we were
using two micron for size membranes and
that is a design choice that can be
buried in the future in order to test
the effects of cells traveling for
example to measure metastasis so one of
the important features of this design
was to get the fluid flow to pass
through the tissue not just over it
because we want to pick up paracrine
signals and carry them to the downstream
tissue and so this is a result from a
model of fluid flow simulation and konso
multiphysics and there's the tissue
right there so you can see it appearing
and disappearing
and I'm Jo found that by placing an
inlet on the upper left and an outlet on
the lower right he was able to drive
fluid flow pretty much straight down
through that issue so that he could pick
up anything that was being secreted and
carry it out other designs where the
inlets were both on the same side or
both on the top or both on the bottom
really didn't provide this flow through
we fabricated this using standard PDMS
micro fluidics once again with a three
layer chip and a trackage membrane that
goes beneath the tissues in order to
hold them in place and restore some
movement and then we needed to validate
how proteins moved between slices and
whether proteins secreted by one tissue
could indeed be captured by another
tissue and so to do that we set up a
simple model system we made mock tissues
out of agarose and loaded them
separately with either a fluorescent
protein coupled to new travelens shown
on the top or by channel a to beat shown
on the bottom so this is to model or a
scepter ligand pair and we could
quantify the fluorescent intensity in
those maka tissues before the experiment
and of course only the protein loaded
slice as bright fluorescence and then we
cultured these overnight you know in the
incubator with continuous fluid flow the
way that we would do for its issues and
we saw that indeed all of that
fluorescent protein was captured by the
receptors in the other tissue after 24
hours with minimal loss to the device
and that was achieved by blocking the
the channels in a particular way with
ESA beforehand and if you're curious
about that you can look in the paper
okay so finally as a proof-of-concept we
had this chip that we knew could support
two slices of of gel or tissue and and
have proteins move between them and so
we asked to what extent can this model
some of the features of tumor immunity
and we started off with just one feature
which was that we know that in vivo
often the lymph nodes are
immunosuppressed by the tumor meaning
that the T cells can no longer respond
to really any type of stimulus very well
so we asked to what extent that could be
mimicked by the chip so we did an
experiment where we had a mouse that was
this is carrying a forty one breast
cancer tumor and then we collected its
lymph nodes and we did a measure of the
capacity of the T cells to respond to
stimulus we hit them with a anti cd3
antibody and we measure how much of a
cytokine called interferon gamma they
secreted and what you see is that naive
my secrete a lot of interferon gamma
where as lymph nodes from the tumor the
tumor bearing animal don't secrete much
interferon gamma at all and so we asked
could we replicate that on the chip so
we took lymph nodes that were from non
draining nodes from a tumor bearing
mouse and then coupled them with a tumor
and cultured overnight and for
comparison we took those same lymph
nodes other slices from those nodes and
cultured them with healthy tissue a fat
pad and we found that here culture with
the tumor again suppressed a response of
the t-cells
compared to the healthy fat so that was
really exciting because this is the
first indication of immuno suppression
on a chip with intact tissue and moving
forward we are hoping to further test
other features of immunosuppression and
and the interaction between lymph nodes
and fuse from tumors in order to see if
we have a model here of tumor immunity
that could for example be used to test
new therapies but this type of model
that holds to tissue slices I would
argue is is applicable to other things
besides tumor immunity and so maybe
you're having some ideas for your own
work this could be applied to brain
immunity or even other non immune
systems such as the gut brain access and
other interaural interactions that
people are interested in okay so just to
wrap up I've talked to you about the
combination of ex vivo samples of tissue
with micro fluidics and how this
provides the experimental control that
you would get with a cell culture dish
but preserves the spatial structure the
tissues are isolated from other organs
in the body which made me go too bad
depending on what you're trying to ask
about and I've shown you two
applications one
local drug delivery and one in multi
tissue communication others have used
this type of system for personalized
drug screening and for long-term tissue
culture and differentiation and there's
lots still to do here so there's really
only a handful of labs in the world that
combined two intact issues with micro
fluidics and so more work is needed and
developing various methods for on-chip
analysis of these tissues particularly
with spatial resolution but also with
high content omics type technologies on
chip long term culture of tissues is
still a major challenge for many tissue
types and then using these technologies
by collaborating with the biologists who
care about these tissues in order to
answer biological questions and develop
new therapies for disease that's a huge
outstanding need and we don't want to
just make technologies right we want to
use them to to better human health in
this case okay so I'd like to thank my
lab I showed you the people who were
doing the work along the way and I'd
also definitely like to thank our
collaborator professor Jennifer Munson
at Virginia Tech who was instrumental in
the tumor immune study that I showed you
we also worked with John Lukens and
Melanie Risk Kowski at the University of
Virginia and this work was generously
funded by the NIH and the Hartwell
foundation and a number of excellent
foundations so thank you to them and I'd
like to remind you to just ask questions
if you have them and I'll respond to
them by email